So speaking of Taylor Swift our next
story is about
women's inherent nature to never be
happy now guys I don't
I don't want you to misconstrue this I
don't say this to hate on women but I
think as women it's helpful to know how
we're just like naturally wired to be
and I don't I I genuinely don't know
what it is but I really think it's since
Adam and Eve right Eve was in the garden
with Adam and they had everything life
was perfect and then the serpent got
into Eve's ear and said no this isn't
good enough eat the apple eat the apple
and then Eve convinced Adam to eat the
apple and I really think the greatest
sin of man was listening to women
because I really think women are a weak
spot in the family unit because we are
so susceptible to propaganda
and we want to be cool we want to adapt
to the group I don't I don't say this
like I'm happy about it
but I just think when we start to look
at Trends in society we start to look at
how women are wired the things that we
do
it just doesn't seem like anything makes
us happy
um it seems like we're almost happy when
there's problems I can't explain it I
don't understand why but you know Taylor
Swift is a world-renowned superstar
you know she is so rich this girl's like
I I don't know I think I just saw she
gave over a hundred K to each trucker
that was on her tour something like that
and you know genuinely I don't think
Taylor is a bad person but I do think
she has been infected with this mindset
where she paints herself as a victim in
every relationship that she's in and
unfortunately you know for the last
decade nobody's told her the truth and
unfortunately you can see how Society
has almost been going through the same
thing and most women have been going
through the same thing because of how
powerful and influential Taylor is like
you don't become a world-renowned
superstar without having some people
relate to your music and in every album
that she writes you know she's the
victim
um and you can just see this like
Trope of of Taylor Swift it's so funny
because if you look at her earlier stuff
she's like this sweet girl she's not
really political and then you know money
and fame and attention
she gets all of it and you can just see
her becoming more and more feminist over
time having more and more failed
relationships over time
um to the point where her last
relationship it's rumored that it ended
because he really wanted to settle down
and she really wanted to go on tour and
there's nothing wrong with either of
those things but it goes to show that
women can have everything and still
never be happy you know she's at the
point where you know I think she's 33
she doesn't have much time left if she
wants to have children
um and yet She'll always pick her career
over a family and I genuinely have no
problem with women picking what they
want to pick I think a lot of people
misconstrue my opinions because I I
don't have a problem with women choosing
things what I have a problem with is the
whining later I and we just have this
tendency so Taylor Swift is going to
talk about a business deal that she did
when she was 18 maybe 16 I don't know
younger where she signed her music away
her music rights away and what happened
with those rights let's pull the clip
after I was denied the chance to
purchase my music outright my entire
catalog was sold to scooter bronze
Ithaca Holdings in a deal that I'm told
was funded by the Soros family 23
capital and the Carlisle Group
yet to this day
none of these investors
have ever bothered to contact me or my
team directly
to perform their due diligence on their
investment
on their investment in me
to ask how I might feel about the new
owner of my art
the music I wrote the videos videos I
created
photos of me my handwriting
my album designs
and of course scooter never contacted me
or my team to discuss it prior to the
sale or even when it was announced
I'm fairly certain he knew exactly how
it would feel about it though and let me
just say that the definition
of the toxic male privilege in our
industry is people saying but he's
always been nice to me when I'm raising
valid concerns about artists and their
rights to own their music
and of course he's nice to you if you're
in this room you have something he needs
the fact is that private Equity is what
enabled this man to think according to
his own social media post
that he could buy me
but I'm obviously not going willingly
yet the most amazing thing was to
discover that it would be the women in
our industry who would have my back
and show me the most vocal support at
one of the most difficult times and I
will never ever forget it like
ever so let me get this straight
like
this is my issue
you know
women if you're gonna go into a man's
world then take what comes with it
you're telling me that you are entitled
for another guy who owns the rights to
your music to ask you how you feel about
it
and this is why we don't get taken
seriously like I can't even I can't even
blame the guys for not taking us
seriously because you know she she goes
into a man's world and then whines when
it's Cutthroat that's what a man's world
is it's not it's it's a Cutthroat world
it's always competitive and nobody has
to ask you how you freaking feel about
it all right this woman is worth
780 million and she is still whining
why and I just cannot stand it and did
you hear that he's always been nice to
me is the toxic masculine
what did she say the toxic masculine
trait uh
I would say that about a woman too
and and this is the thing like
I have no problem with women wanting to
go into media and entertainment uh look
at look at me look at me I'm here
but what I what I do have an issue with
is women going into these industries and
complaining later saying everyone wants
to sleep with you saying everybody's out
to get you when honestly
half of these chicks flirt first and two
half of the time
these women are just whining they're not
giving special treatment because they're
so used to the pretty privilege
um that they've gotten their whole life
and I'm sorry when it comes down to
money and dollars
um and I'm sorry when it comes down to
money and dollars men don't care they're
here to make money they're not here to
ask you how you feel about things and
the more women that do this the more I
just say ban them you know sometimes I
have policy prescriptions
that wouldn't necessarily benefit me
personally I think about this sometimes
but it's like if women and I think about
this with sports with women's sports
it's like you give women a league you
give women more pay and what do they do
wine complain blame the patriarchy and I
just say if you guys are going to keep
whining If You're Gonna Keep bitching if
you're going to keep moaning get out of
here and she also said something
peculiar as well where she said all of
the women in the industry supported me
and you'll see this like innate Instinct
of women to protect other women at all
costs it just baffles me because even
when women are saying absolutely asinine
stupid things it's like we still protect
them and I don't understand why